ici il faut faire une clôture qui va
avoir environ 40 pieds de long la
sécurité de la piscine creusée d'andré
saint-hilaire sera jugée non conforme à
partir du 1er juillet 2023 je n'ai pas
vraiment chaud et c'est avec
l'aménagement de ma cour d'y aller avec
une clôture additionnel un règlement du
gouvernement du québec oblige tous les
propriétaires de piscine à rendre leurs
plans d'eau inaccessible à un enfant en
bas âge depuis la résidence
c'est la fin d'un droit acquis pour les
installations construites avant 2010
dans le but d'éviter des noyades l'enjeu
et très financier le pompier à la
retraite constate que la facture explose
les soumissions que j'ai eu des gens qui
m'ont dit heureux de faire souffler deux
hommes s'étaient peut-être 4000 en ruine
de coûts est maintenant rendu de 9200
d'orange le fabricant et installateur
clôture davioud est aux premières loges
la flambée des prix des matières
premières comme l'acier et de la pénurie
demandeurs à cause de la loi dadt amende
à l'augmenter le cocktail est parfait et
puis on vraiment doublé depuis un an et
demi environ
radio canada a appris que le contexte
économique force la main de la ministre
des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation andré la forêt un délai de
grâce est en cours de consultation
il est donc proposé de repousser le tout
au 30 septembre 2000 25 donc de plus de
2 à on repousse encore un échéance les
coroners nous disent pratiquement neuf
fois sur dix les noyades ont eu lieu
dans les piscines résidentielles
une pétition en ligne ayant recueilli
près de quatorze mille signatures
demandent au gouvernement de transférer
l'obligation aux futurs propriétaires
chaque fois qu'on peut amener une
sécurité additionnelle par une
réglementation j'en suis pas content
mais il faut quand même qu'il ya un ied
qui viennent assister les propriétaires
une telle aide comme un crédit d'impôt
pourrait néanmoins créer une injustice
pour ceux qui ont déjà réalisé leurs
travaux ils si matthew zions radio
canada montréal